right well I was born on May which is a
fifth month and on the 13th day of May
ad is mathematically that's vaguely
interesting because these are both
Pythagorean primes
right okay well if we look at five then
we can write five as the sum of two
squares so one squared plus two squared
is equal to five now if we take 13 see
if we can work that one out well 13 is 9
plus 4 so 4 is just 2 squared and 3
squared is 9 so that gives me now the
next one
17 do that as well because 17 is 4
squared plus 1 squared which is another
Pythagorean prime Pythagorean we've all
heard of Pythagoras who was a very
famous mathematician so why why do these
numbers bear his name well if we
remember our right angle triangle so
we've got a right angle there and
there's the eye potenuse and Pythagoras
tells us that if this thing is of length
a and this bit here is of length B then
a squared plus B squared equals C
squared
that's Pythagoras theorem okay now of
course a and B don't have to be they
don't have to be integers and C doesn't
have to be an integer they could be any
number this could be 3.2 inches this can
be 5.75 inches whatever C is then but we
can play this game with integers and
when we do we generate these Pythagorean
primes if we look at if we look at 13
then it turns out all of these numbers
can be written as 4 n plus 1 so 13 is
equal to 4 n plus 1 where n is equal to
3 if we take 17 then 17 is 4 n plus 1
where n is equal to 4 so the Pythagorean
Prime's have this we generate them this
way but they've also got this
interesting property can I put any end
in
to get a Pythagorean primer only certain
ends will do it no no for example if we
just take the next one in this series if
we put N equals 5 then N equals 5 gives
me of course 21 okay so that's just 20
plus 1 and although 21 is an odd number
it's not a prime number because is equal
to 7 times 3 so 21 is not a prime and
it's obviously if it's not not even a
prime so it's obviously not a
Pythagorean prime so it's not all values
of n that give me these just special
values we mentioned at the start that
your birthday is the 13th of the fifth
and they're both Pythagorean primes yes
can you remember at what point in your
life you realized your birthday was two
Pythagorean bronze when you asked me to
talk about doublers Allah I I have a
really favorite Pythagorean prime which
I'd like to tell you about and then I
just realized that 13 and 5 are two nice
small ones okay tell me about your
favorite well my favorite one of course
is 137 and it doesn't know by the way
professor eaves is obsessed with the
number 137 and you'll see him talking
about it in multiple videos not really
that obsessed but anyway the course is
that the inverse fine-structure constant
which we use a lot in atomic physics and
any properties to do with the elect
electrons and their quantum behavior the
fine-structure constant alpha its
inverses is almost 137 not exactly 137
and lo and behold 137 is a nice
Pythagorean prime which is which i think
is is quite quite nice and if we work
that one out of course we see how can we
make it up well little bit of thinking
we can see that LM squared gives me 121
and then if I take 4 squared which is 16
that adds up to 137 so can we draw the
Pythagorean triangle for that it would
look something like this I've changed
the scale of my units here a little bit
so we've got 11 there for there
then this diagonal is the square root of
137 a nice Pythagorean prime so just to
be absolutely clear the hypotenuse of a
right angled triangle when the other two
sides are integers won't be a
Pythagorean it's square root is the
Pythagorean price where ya
thirty-eight how many second many arrows
do you want so the next one let's say we
did three ^ ^ ^ our arrow bye-bye - ooh
call this and that will give you the
third perfect number